i will continue to raise funds until we
win the revolution
personalised portraits drawn on demand
the artist known as burmese beast is
among those crowdfunding resistance to
myanmar's military government we're not
revealing her name or identity for her
safety
when the coup happened and the
revolution began
the civil disobedience movement started
and i also started supporting a couple
of cdmas with my own income and i soon
realized of course that there are a lot
more cdmas than i can ever afford to
support
so i started to find different ways to
increase my income
that's how i started my portraits in
exchange for donations fundraiser
we try very hard to ensure that the
funds reach areas of real and urgent
needs
and prioritization is the utmost
importance
[Music]
from art sketches to pop-up food this
stall in singapore another small thread
in a global fundraising web sending
cashback to the country to oppose the
coup
at the core of the opposition is the
country's shadow national unity
government an alliance led by aung san
tsuchi supporters
in december the nug said it would accept
cryptocurrency tether for local use
it's also selling special bonds with
which it hopes to raise as much as 1
billion us dollars
one of the men helping coordinate this
is former political prisoner lynn thant
now in exile in the czech republic we
tracked him down in prague
the problem is we don't have the you
know
the central bank in myanmar because the
military did control everything so we
should have the financial fluids
and that's why we should have defense so
that's why we are trying to get you know
the uh donations
this is just so-called bonds and then
in the future they will get something
special for example you know the tax
reductions or something like that
military marked the 75th anniversary of
the country's union day with a grand
parade and a call for national unity but
with foreign investors leaving and a
major cash shortage on the ground it's
also looking to alternative financing a
regime spokesman told bloomberg
on the digital currency we are still in
discussions with some companies in terms
of technology and financial reliability
we are now in discussions with at least
five companies which are willing to
cooperate with us to launch an online
lottery in which anyone from anywhere in
the world can join and test their luck
one year on since the coup the economic
toll is stark the world bank says the
economy shrunk 18 in the last fiscal
year and the outlook remains bleak but
those funding the resistance remain ever
hopeful
i think that
it is very important that we take our
roles
in this revolution and do whatever we
can to support this cause because this
is a cause that's worthy of
our time of our lives
different people have different hopes
but their fear is that if we lose our
country we'll become
a wasteland
a wasteland where
nobody is able to dare to dream to hope
for a better future anymore
[Music]
you